the people of minsk have reached their
boiling point
there he stands a fascist there i will
remember him for my whole life
once more they took to the streets to
demand president lukashenko step
down only to be met by the full strength
of security forces
[Applause]
sunday saw some of the most violent
tactics yet from authorities
who sent military vehicles into the
center of the capital
[Music]
groups of black-clad masked police were
filmed running towards
protesters opposition news sites aired
this witness footage
of them pulling protesters to the ground
[Music]
and dragging them into black minibuses
the scene seemed to clash with those
filmed just one day earlier
when president lukashenko met with his
jailed political opponents to discuss
reforms
we shouldn't only be focused on the
constitution
i'm trying to convince not only your
supporters but the whole of society
that one needs to look at things more
broadly
the bizarre television meeting did
little to dissuade
many from participating in sunday's
protests
he wants to look like the kind leader so
that the elderly in front of the
television
think that he's really ready for the
dialogue with the opposition
he's just a terrorist talking to his
hostages and he's trying to sell that to
us as negotiations
demonstrators have vowed to continue
taking to the streets
until president lukashenko steps down
i'm joined now for more by the
belarusian journalist hana liu bakova
following developments for us good
morning to you thanks so much for coming
in
protesters have been taking to the
streets for two months now
as we've seen in very large numbers do
you see the demonstrations
continuing at their current levels
well yes there is a lot of anger and
basically no demand of the protesters
was
met so i imagine people coming out to
the streets
again and again every sunday of course
the protest might change their form they
might get
institutionalized in any like in a new
form in any way
but i imagine people are still very much
mobilized and very much you know
demanding change and they just disagree
with the authorities and with lukashenka
okay now over the weekend lukashenko met
with uh jailed
activists in in the prison where they're
being held
what do you make of that
well that was his attempt to show that
he's ready for
the constitutional reform but many
people do not believe in this because
well um svetona tikanovska who is
considered the national leader she was
in charge of this kind of constitutional
reform from her side and the person
the the politician another levitica who
was
kind of working on these changes he was
jailed
so at the same time luka shank is trying
to show that he is ready for this reform
but we can see that well
he just wants to get this kind of
process under control
and people clearly understand it it's
kind of lukashenka's another
way to to kind of deceive people
you know to to um to introduce his own
kind of process and
and all of this but but people do not
believe in this
well another group that's looking at
this serious along with the seriously
along with the people
of belarus are the eu foreign ministers
they're meeting today to discuss
possible new sanctions on belarus
do you think that will make any
difference in minsk
well i think that's what many people
expect only yesterday nearly 600 people
were detained and many were badly
injured they were hospitalized with
broken bones stung grenades were used
people were shot with rubber bullets
so we are coming back to the situation
of august
during the worst day thousands of people
were detained
so i think people just expect justice
they want justice
justice they demand it and no criminal
case was launched into
like to investigate the atrocities of
the authorities
so i think the only way for people to
kind of get this justice
is to see that those people who were
responsible for the election rigging
and for brutal oppression for brutal
repressions and violence of the police
so
they people these people would be um
somehow punished
either by sanctions or international
investigation
so that's what many people in belarus do
expect
indeed honolulu bakova belarusian
journalist coming in for us today thanks
you very much for that
thank you